un interne elle est une jeune femme
ambitieuse et volontaire amoureuse de la
nature
depuis qu'elle est toute petite elle a
pour objectif d'exercer un métier
directement en contact avec la nature
c'est donc tout naturellement qu'elle
s'oriente vers l'agriculture diplômés et
passionné en agroécologie elle décide
d'aller au bout de ses rêves et de
devenir agricultrice bio
malgré sa motivation ana doit trouver
des terres à cultiver
mais à la réunion les terres agricoles
sont rares elles tapent à toutes les
portes et constate qu'il est très
difficile de se procurer un terrain à
cultiver
jusqu'au jour où elle prend connaissance
que le conseil général met à disposition
des terres classé en espace naturel
sensible à destination principale des
jeunes agriculteurs
ça fait trois ans que j'ai décidé de
m'installer en agriculture biologique
je cherchais un métier en fait dans
lequel je sois en harmonie avec la
nature
travailler dehors au grand air et avoir
un travail physique aussi c'était
important au départ dans mon projet j'ai
fait des stages dans des fermes
agricoles biologiques dans la région de
l'ouest et je cherchais donc un terrain
de 2 hectares 1 à 2 hectares disons dans
l'ouest pour pouvoir m'installer
c'est à la télévision que j'ai vu que le
conseil général cherche et des jeunes
agriculteurs pour s'occuper de deux
terrains en friche qu'il possédait
depuis longtemps et j'ai décidé de
d'envoyer un dossier
j'ai envoyé mon projet de fin d'études
de
brevet professionnel de responsable
d'exploitation agricole c'est un projet
donc d'agriculture biologique diversifié
il a plu je suis très très fière et
heureuse qu'il est qu'il est plus aux
instances du conseil général parce que
vraiment je sais le genre de terrain qui
va très bien convenir à mon projet anna
est très heureuse et motiver les idées
ne manquent pas pour exploiter au mieux
ce terrain son nouveau terrain elle
propose de valoriser le site par des
cultures maraîchères en plein champ et
sous serre par des productions végétales
diverses ainsi flore pitaya arbres
fruitiers de toutes sortes et par un
petit élevage de volailles l'objectif
étant de créer un espace agro
écologiques ou les pratiques agricoles
respecte la biodiversité en harmonie
avec l'écosystème de cet espace naturel
sensible
je vais utiliser la partie haute qui à
ceplan pour mettre des légumes de plein
champ adapté à la situation c'est à dire
nous sommes à 950 mètres d'altitude ici
donc ça va être du chou du chouchou des
brèdes peu épinards salades
il va y avoir aussi du chou fleur des
artichauts et on manque beaucoup de
fruits bio à la réunion donc j'espère
pouvoir planter donc des agrumes dépêché
des pommiers peut-être j'aimerais aussi
beaucoup de planter des arbres
endémiques donc tamarins watt'notes
arbres de bois de couleur des eaux pour
arriver à conserver l'environnement
naturel et même lui redonner la nature
qu'il a un petit peu perdues peut-être
voilà pour favoriser en fait la venue
des oiseaux qui sont nombreux dans l'art
et dans la région
il y aura aussi des fleurs mellifères
parce que il est important qu'il y ait
aussi des abeilles pour pouvoir
polliniser que ce soit les arbres
fruitiers ou vous les légumes
ils ont tous besoin d'être polliniser
donc il y aura aussi quelques ruches et
les ruches sont en général très heureuse
en bordure de forêt comme c'est ici
l'utiliser dns comme terres à cultiver
tout en respectant l'environnement est
une des solutions utiles et efficaces à
tous les acteurs de ce dispositif
et durable pour les nouveaux
agriculteurs et un avenir éco citoyen
pour la réunion est économiquement
efficace socialement équitable et
écologiquement durable les trois piliers
du développement durable devient ainsi
une réalité concrète
via cette idée innovante en louant à bas
prix ces espaces naturels sensibles à
des agriculteurs
le conseil général permet la
dynamisation de tout un secteur de
l'économie agricole d'un côté il y avait
des terres de qualité non cultivées de
l'autre des agriculteurs qui ont besoin
de terres pour travailler il suffisait
d'avoir l'idée de réunir les deux pour
relancer l'agriculture réunionnaise sur
une nouvelle voie pleine d'avenir est
porteuse d'emplois